what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with Ultimate Spider-Man
venomor I.E the story where Miles
Morales fights Venom and the ending of
the story is amazing so I'm really
excited to see how you guys respond to
this but what this does is this
initially opens up with Miles Morales
and his family enjoying dinner together
but when there's a knock on the door and
Jefferson Davis the father of Miles
answers it reporters come barging in and
then asking him whether or not he's like
the new Spider-Man is a true heat
overpowered Hydra all that kind of stuff
now the reason why they're asking
Jefferson Davis these questions is
twofold the first has to do with a
reporter named Betty Brandt and the
second has to do with Jefferson Davis
own history so focusing on Betty brand
here for a second the way this played
out is Betty Brandt being a reporter
working at The Daily Bugle she had
uncovered what she believed to be the
true identity of the current Spider-Man
running around that basically replaced
Peter Parker after Peter died in the
Ultimate Universe and she believed that
person to be Jefferson Davis now a lot
of that was just based on Jefferson's
own history along with her just kind of
putting pieces together and maybe
cooking the books a little bit and the
reason why I say that is because
Jefferson is incredibly accomplished in
the sense that there was one point where
he was captured by Hydra he overpowered
them and then executed a whole bunch of
Hydra soldiers there was a point where
he became a spy for shield working for
Nick Fury and spied on a guy named Turk
who was a criminal warlord so the guys
got the kind of chops that you would
expect from a person who would be a
Spider-Man but the fact that Miles lives
in the same home as Jefferson gave Betty
Brandt the belief that Jefferson was
Spider-Man because while miles is
running out and doing all the Spider-Man
stuff his base of operations is in that
general area so again it was really more
Betty Brant trying to put the pieces
together now of course Jefferson Davis
gets eight kinds of pissed off when
reporters barge into his house and start
asking him questions and so once he
forces all of them out he ends up
leaving right he ends up going for a
walk and in that moment he's immediately
set upon by the Venom symbiote who's
been hunting for Spider-Man now here's
one of the things we need to explain
here the Venom symbiote in the Ultimate
Universe is not not the same as the
Venom symbiote in the main Marvel
Universe in Earth 616 in Marvel Comics
the main Marvel Universe the Venom
symbiote is an alien that was created by
a guy called null in the Ultimate
Universe the Venom symbiote is actually
a biosuit it was an attempt to create a
kind of healing suit that could
basically heal anybody from virtually
any injuries they sustain the grand idea
was to use it for military applications
bonded to soldiers send them into the
field that kind of a thing but as time
progressed and when you had the original
War of the Symbiote with Eddie Brock Jr
being the original host for Venom that
initially was believed the Venom Suit
was destroyed now little bits of the
Venom Suit survived and it's been taken
by different people over the years in
this instance the version of Venom that
we see here is actually owned and
operated by roxon Industries but we'll
talk about them here in a second the
important takeaway from this is that
when the Venom Suit shows up of course
Miles Morales responds exactly the way
that you would expect him to now one of
the things that I want to specify here
is that miles is still figuring out how
to be Spider-Man and the reason why this
this matters is because with Venom going
after Jefferson and Miles responding if
this was Peter Parker he would have
lured Venom to a location where there
were no bystanders there were no
innocence instead miles is fighting out
of desperation the desire to keep his
father safe and to keep different
civilians around here protected but that
lack of experience comes to bear in the
sense that he's almost immediately
overwhelmed by Venom and the fight is
amazing I'm he abdued Venom absolutely
pummels this guy when it comes to
Spider-Man facing off against villain's
wreck Peter Parker or really any
Spider-Man just kind of jokes and does
all kinds of little cracky things and so
on and so forth but through it all Peter
very rarely ever loses the upper hand
right Miles Morales ain't that way and
so while miles is getting thrown around
like a ragdoll I mean just getting
absolutely crushed by Venom that in turn
like these Cops show up and start
opening fire so then Venom turns his
attention to the cops and starts to help
them finish with all of their living now
of course miles jumps in Miles jumps in
and starts attacking the Venom symbiote
yet again now one of the things that I
will give miles here right I got to give
miles credit for this this kid's
fighting with every ounce of strength
that he has and he's doing his best
right I don't mean to discredit him and
be like miles you are a trash Spider-Man
he's doing his best now one of the
things that I also want to point out
here is that miles is aware of Venom to
a degree and it's only because of the
fact that he saw YouTube videos where
Spider-Man where Peter Parker Spider-Man
had fought Venom so that's the only
reason why he's even aware of the idea
of like Venom's weaknesses but what he
ends up doing is using his Venom blast
on Venom and when that happens literally
the Venom Samia just kind of succumbs to
it and just sort of explodes it's not
really like blowing up all over the
place but it kind of scrambles the
nature of the Symbiote and ends up
sending the Symbiote running and so
following that Jefferson Davis is taken
to the hospital now what follows next is
morally questionable at best and just
downright diabolical at worst but we'll
talk about that here in a second what we
actually end up doing here is Miles gets
information because one of the things
she remember is that Miles has never
actually faced off against Venom and he
doesn't even know why Venom's coming
after him in the first place or why he
even went after Jefferson Davis and so
what you end up having is Miles and his
friend Genki meeting with Gwen Stacy and
Mary Jane Watson now these two are
incredibly important in relation to this
part of the story and the reason why is
because Gwen Stacy was caught up in the
original War of the Symbiote and when I
say that I mean she was basically killed
by the original Eddie Brock Jr Venom
right the original host for the Venom
symbia and she was in fact absorbed into
it which was kind of a crazy thing
because as this conversation unfolds
what they say here is that venom has a
deep-rooted DNA genetic connection to
the Parker bloodline now the reason for
this is because of the fact that the
Venom symbiote was in one part created
by Peter Parker's dad in The Ultimate
Universe he was one half of the creation
team that led to Venom coming into
existence and so what she says is it was
originally created from Peter's father's
DNA and it had literally stopped and
hunted Peter once he or Venom are in
whatever you want to call it realized
who Peter was now with Peter gone it may
just be looking for you because like him
you became Spider-Man so whatever was
special about Peter Parker genetically
you might have the same thing and so the
reason why this matters is that with
like Betty Brent dead and Peter Parker
dead no one really knows why the Venom
symbiote is doing what it's doing right
now it feeds on energy and life force so
the best estimation we can get is that
it's just kind of driven by a desire to
absorb whoever Spider-Man is and then
expand its own abilities based on the
powers of that Spider-Man but having
said that when I mentioned that what
happened next was just morally
questionable at best and just diabolical
at worst the Venom symbiote breaks into
a hospital it literally attacks a
hospital who does that man right you
guys remember that scene from The
Punisher when Frank Castle rolled into
the hospital and was just shooting the
place up in the TV show it's like that
man it's just some villainous stuff
right I mean you literally have people
on gurneys the Symbiotes attacking them
right folks who are just like in the
middle of surgery or bleeding out right
or like paralyzed or something like that
I mean it's a slaughterhouse man and it
keeps talking about how like give me
Spider-Man and I will let all of you
leave with your lives right I will let
all of you guys survive it's diabolical
dude it's pretty messed up
but here's the thing right here's the
thing so once miles shows up here right
miles has learned from his fight with
the Venom Symbian and that's one of the
things that made miles story so cool is
because as the reader much like what we
saw with Ultimate Spider-Man Peter
Parker you saw him learn how to become
Spider-Man as he was operating as
Spider-Man and that's one of the reasons
why as soon as he shows back up here he
immediately starts using his Venom blast
on Venom but lest we forget while miles
has adapted and learned with his Venom
blast and his first fight with uh with
Venom so has the Symbian and so instead
of allowing miles to stay in close
proximity to him for any measure of time
he just starts throwing him around
because he realizes that even with Miles
being Spider-Man and having enhanced
speed and reflexes and so on and so
forth the most effective thing he can do
is to shut miles down as fast as humanly
possible to literally overpower him to
hammer him so hard that he's completely
overwhelmed and exhausted within minutes
and that's exactly what happens I mean
this them see me it comes in and it's
just like round two son ding ding and it
like literally takes it to him man he
beats his ass like he owes him money and
then as soon as that happens he
immediately absorbs miles and it's the
smartest move for the Venom symbia to do
here it's the smartest thing he could
have possibly done now while this whole
thing's watching miles mom is freaking
out right she's literally watching her
son being eaten by like a giant monster
but one of the big moments that came out
of this story right one of the biggest
things that come out of the story is
this is when we learn that Miles mom
knew he was Spider-Man and we didn't
know beforehand not that I'm aware of
right as far as I'm aware before this
moment we never knew that Miles mom knew
that he was Spider-Man but once she
realized that that was the case she
starts begging the Venom Symbian please
let my son go and the symbias just like
your family has caused me a lot of
trouble you have no idea what I have
done to get here and seemingly he's
gonna consume her too but what miles
does is as he's trapped inside the Venom
symbiote he literally unload this
massive Venom blast and it's just this
really really amazing moment because
when that happens we end up finding out
the current host of the Venom symbiote
is a guy named Marcus now we'll learn
more about him here in a second because
his motivation is really really cool but
the other thing that ends up happening
here and this was a huge moment when
this happened in the comic is that Rio
the mother of miles is caught in the
crossfire with the cops and she's
mortally injured she's literally killed
by the police officers and everything
starts going nuts after that because
what we end up doing is we switch over
to roxon Industries now while reports
are coming out right the news is
reporting on everything that's going on
about the whole Venom symbiote and
everything with a guy named Marcus and
so on it is inevitable that Marcus is
going to be traced back to roxon because
Marcus was an employee of Roxanne and in
fact that's what they say right they
like the news says we're still waiting
for official word from roxon as to what
they know about this man and how this
has all come to pass was Marcus's
violent mutation some sort of experiment
or an accident gone wrong the reality
here is that if roxon doesn't get out in
front of this before things snowball too
fast conspiracy theories and everything
will take hold and so the head of rock
song Right the man himself he says
you'll inform the media that the roxon
corporation is working with authorities
in all capacities so that this terrible
tragedy can be put behind us but what
we're actually doing here is making sure
that no one can connect what happened
tonight to What's Happening Here what we
are doing is waiting until this all
blows over and then we will find out
exactly what this Marcus was doing with
the Symbiote in the first place what
we're going to do is wait until no one
is watching us and when I give the word
I want to find out how Spider-Man became
Spider-Man and why we can't figure out
how to make a Spider-Man for ourselves
and so that's the big thing here is
because roxon basically got their hands
on a sample of the Venom symbiote
following the defeat and death of Eddie
Brock Jr and so roxon has been using the
Symbiote and experimenting on it and
trying to find a way to create their own
version of Spider-Man now presumably
what roxon would do is they would kill
Miles Morales Spider-Man and replace him
with their own and that version of
Spider-Man would be beholden to rock
song but for Miles himself when he wakes
up the next morning and the reality hits
him that his mom is dead he immediately
freaks out and in feeling the same kind
of pain that Peter felt in losing Uncle
Ben he quits right he's like I'm done he
gives up being Spider-Man tears the suit
apart and wants to have nothing to do
with it anymore but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace